ho ho ho lovelies let's make some
holiday hunger crushing combos merry
christmas you filthy animals
hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen
[Music]
today we are back with another episode
of turning your trigger foods or fear
foods into hunger crushing combos
holiday edition first guys i want to
jump in here for a hot minute to talk
about my sponsor squarespace so if
you're not familiar squarespace is an
all-in-one platform where you can build
a website blog online store or just use
their marketing tools and analytics they
have so many new awesome features that
are just perfect for new entrepreneurs
and hobbyists who are looking to get
their passion out into the world so for
example if you want to blog they have an
easy integrated commenting system and
blogging tools for sharing and
scheduling posts if you're super into
your instagram or facebook you can sync
those up with your website to make sure
everything works together seamlessly
they also have all of your analytics
there so you can see how your site is
performing and then adjust your content
strategy based on your stats honestly i
wish this kind of support was available
when i was just starting blogging like a
decade ago because it would have saved
me so much energy money and time but if
you're interested in getting started you
can check out squarespace.com for a free
trial and when you're ready to launch go
to squarespace.com
abbey sharp to save 10 off of your first
purchase of a website or domain so i
surveyed you on your holiday related
fear foods or trigger foods things that
really made you feel uneasy or like you
were going to overeat or binge on during
the holidays and i want to show you how
to turn them into hunger crushing combos
yes
you got this i am feeling festive and i
am very hungry so let's do it okay so
first things first i want to share with
you how i put together an inherently
balanced holiday meal because i know a
lot of you guys think about holiday
foods as being super indulgent or junk
or bad but i want you to change your
perspective for a second because i
actually see
a lot of inherent balance i see a hunger
crushing combo i see
a lot of beautiful
color and honestly it looks delicious
i'm like my mouth is watering
let me show you what we're working with
we've got lots of protein in our turkey
or whatever kind of protein you guys
serve for your holiday feast we've got
fiber in our potatoes and our squash and
our green beans and in our cranberry
sauce
we've got some fats in the gravy and
there's probably lots of butter in there
for good measure i don't know it looks
like a hunger crushing combo to me it
looks like color it looks like variety
it looks like tons of nutrition and love
and joy and pleasure and fun and family
and
i love the holidays but i'm ready for
dessert so let's talk about some of your
traditional trigger foods or holiday
fear foods and how i'm going to turn
them into hunger crushing combos let's
do it all right love us now this is a
sensitive topic but does anyone remember
my holiday prep video from
last christmas you know the time that i
attempted
and
failed
pretty hard at assembling
this
well she's back to haunt me
[Music]
because a lot of you told me that
cookies specifically gingerbread cookies
and gingerbread men or women cookies or
people cookies were
a trigger food for you and i gotta tell
you they are a trigger food for me too
at this point not because of the
calories or the sugar or the fat but
because their decoration and assembly
like haunts me
i just feel like such a failure in life
i can't even put together a
friggin
gingerbread house
but i would just like to draw some
attention to the false advertising here
it says easy build if you can see that
it was not easy
all right okay so so what i did not
follow instructions at all nor did i
acknowledge the easy roof builder until
basically i had already attempted and
failed at the project but we're just
gonna keep it simple today and stick to
decorating the gingerbread cookie and
then doing what i'm actually good at
which is turning it into a hunger
crushing combo
big breath in
i'm ready
[Laughter]
run run run as fast as you can you can't
catch me i'm the gingerbread man you're
a monster so i feel like the first step
is to
get into this package somehow they have
really
put a child lock on this all right
here is our one lone gingerbread person
and i'm just gonna stick to this because
this proved too much for me last year
oh dear this is sad
not a great start
not a total betty but a vast improvement
all right let's make a dip yup
all right let's make a little pumpkin
pie dip not gonna measure this we got
some
pure pumpkin puree hear that
that's a gross sound
got some vegan cinnamon spice protein
powder here a little bit more but you
could totally use like a vanilla just
like keeping it super simple as well and
then a little bit of plant-based yogurt
any kind of yogurt will work i'm gonna
give this a stir
[Music]
add a little more cinnamon
and if you want to sweeten it up a
little bit more you can add some maple
syrup
you like sugar huh is there sugar and
syrup
and i always like to add a little pinch
of salt and just a little vanilla as
well
just to add bring out that flavor
[Music]
all right and to finish it off i've got
some hemp hearts of course
and some toasted pumpkin seeds
yum
[Music]
alrighty folks let's talk about this
gorgeous snack platter i mean you could
totally serve this for guests
so we got our gingerbread person we've
got loads and loads of fiber in the
pumpkin puree as well as in all the
fruit we're going to serve on the side
we've got protein in the protein powder
we've got healthy fats in my seeds and
my my pumpkin seeds and my hemp hearts
i'm excited to dig in though i have to
tell you
that i'm kind of sad to see this person
go should we do the head are we barbaric
like that we are
gotta get a good dip
i can make a really terrible sex joke
right now about this but i'm just gonna
dig in
the dip actually makes this
very very stale cookie edible it like
softens it up a little bit
i might just look off the dip
fruit's probably better off him
[Applause]
[Music]
this one is for my hubs uh eggnog he's
obsessed with eggnog
and he's specifically obsessed with
starbucks eggnog latte so he was very
upset when we found out a couple weeks
ago that they have discontinued
the eggnog latte
what kind of grinch move is that
so anyways he was very excited when he
saw that this made an appearance in the
grocery order this week he's not gonna
be so happy when he finds out that
there's not a whole lot left tomorrow
for his latte because i'm turning it
into a hunger crushing combo good for
you
not so much for him let's do it so we
are gonna turn this into an eggnog chia
pudding and she's gonna be good throwing
down
some chia seeds i'm not gonna measure
this but
i'm just gonna eyeball it's about a one
to four ratio chia to liquid situation
and i find that the eggnog
it honestly we don't even need that much
of it to impart a ton of flavor so i'm
gonna do a little bit of that i'm gonna
do a little bit of this kind of protein
almond milk cashew milk situation
give it a little stir
maybe a little cinnamon
just took
i guess i'm at the end of that
and then i like to do just a little bit
of greek yogurt for some extra protein
um
but you could also leave this out if you
didn't want to
[Music]
all right little magic of television
she is ready
to eat all right first we're going to
get in there very dangerously
oh with some pomegranate and oh
she is a beaut oh yeah that is
gonna go right on top of that shape
pudding and i'm going to be very careful
because i'm wearing white oh my goodness
what am i doing
very carefully
who do i think i am
do i think i'm invincible like this is
this is living on the edge
in a white shirt oh my goodness
how am i going to get through this lots
of paper towel lots of paper towel all
right chia pudding down oh yeah
you guys can't smell this but it smells
like the holidays because that eggnog is
so
so potent a little goes a long way very
carefully
very oh my goodness i'm so scared
i just want to take my shirt off right
now i probably should
but i might get demonetized
and
some toasted coconut
guys i thought i got away unscathed
but i was wrong
i don't know if you can see this but
there's a tiny
little red dot
and another one here
and another one here
and now just like that this recipe is
going to cost me like 50 in dry cleaning
but what would i wear but alas it was
worth it
so let's talk about this we've got oh in
that chia pudding hello we got protein
fiber and healthy fats in chia seeds we
got some fats in the coconut plus fiber
we've got fiber in the pomegranate we've
got some more protein in the greek
yogurt
and i mean let's not forget there's
actually a little bit of protein in
eggnog as well so
i don't feel bad about this oh my
goodness
jingle
bells
oh my god the whole family's gonna love
this my kids are going to freak out
this is going in rotation
all year long
[Music]
all right folks candy canes so these
just you know taste smell look like the
holidays to me uh i just hear sleigh
bells jingling ring ting tingling when i
see a candy cane anyone else
but i have to be honest
i don't love them something about
toothpaste flavored candy to me
doesn't really toot my horn i don't know
but my husband loves candy canes and now
my son who just was introduced to candy
canes because i had them in the house
for this video he also is now loving the
candy canes but we're gonna turn these
candy canes into a hunger crushing combo
uh this could be a meal this could be a
snack this is just gonna be delicious so
we're gonna make my sheep pan protein
pancakes candy cane edition let's do it
okay so i've just got some cottage
cheese here and we're gonna puree that
until it gets nice and smooth
okay so my kid my baby is sleeping right
now and i have to tell you that every
second that the food processor or the
blender is blending my heart is like
beating out of my chest being like don't
wake him up don't make them up don't
wake them up it is riveting okay so i've
got a bowl of some oat flour you can use
whole wheat flour as well i'm gonna pop
that into here
and in another edition of mommy heart
attack we're going to take some very
ripe bananas and we're going to puree
that in
as well
and i've also got some from the freezer
i've got
lots of ground flax here it's about
right
a bunch of eggs
got some baking powder
[Music]
some vanilla
lots of cinnamon
[Music]
salt i got lots of hemp hearts you guys
know i love hemp hearts
and now
we mix everything together
all right now we're just going to pour
this down
on a greased baking sheet
give it a nice spread out all to the
edges
[Music]
now we have some fun
lots of mini dark chocolate chips
[Music]
and then
our crushed candy canes
top it off with a little more hemp
hearts
this is going into a
425 degree oven for about 12 minutes
[Music]
how fun
is this
ho ho
ho
all right let's review so we've got
protein in the cottage cheese we've got
fiber in the oat flour plus of course
we've got like hemp hearts in here as
well got some
healthy fats in all of our hemp hearts
and our flax and we got
like candy canes
i'm excited about this these totally
don't need extra maple syrup if you
don't want to add it because they are so
sweet from the candy cane and the
chocolate
but
you know why not
i nailed it guys i
nailed it
[Music]
all right loves let's have some pie
american pie canadian pie could be any
kind of pie
in this case we're doing apple pie but i
totally get that everyone has their own
like holiday pie traditions but pie was
definitely a common holiday fear food
that came up uh when i asked you guys
for your recommendations
now full disclosure i
do not like pie why why
why
why well i like pie filling but i don't
like pie crust so when i'm going to eat
a pie i always want to have like a
graham cracker crust or like a chocolate
cookie crust or
something that's like not a traditional
pie crust but i'm doing this for you
because i love you so we're going to
make this apple pie a little more
abbified with some really great add-ins
that i actually really love that also
happen to make it a hunger crushing
combo let's do it so i suppose i don't
need a whole pie
so we'll just give ourselves a generous
slice here
[Music]
i've got some really good aged cheddar
here
and you know it is actually a classic
pairing to do apple pie
with cheese with cheddar cheese because
it is like a sweet and salty combination
that just hits right
so i'm gonna throw a lot of this on top
all right we got a mountain of cheese
here nice i'm gonna stick it in the
microwave you could also totally just
pop this in the oven oh
now that's a pie
i wanna eat
now while it's still warm i'm gonna add
some pecans for like a cheesy crunchy
pecan top poppy smells the cheese do you
smell the cheese poppy
she smells the cheese
all right
let's talk about it
so we've got our apple pie we've got
protein and some fats in the cheese we
got protein fat and fiber in the nuts
we've got some fiber in the apples let's
not kid ourselves we can at least throw
our apple pie that little bone
and
look how much better it looks like i
would serve that to guests
[Music]
there's a cheese pull and nuts
[Music]
she good
[Music]
okay so how many of you have this same
memory that i have when i was a kid we
used to go to my grandparents house and
one of my favorite things at the
holidays was to bust into their kind of
like cheap drugstore
chocolate box and get to take out the
old chocolate menu
remember one of these this is a fancy
one i really went all out guys i went
all out this is no pot of gold this is a
ferrero rocher themed box of chocolates
so these are all premium
premium
delights
uh fine assortment of chocolate as they
say so anyways i used to get to bust out
the little chocolate menu and select
my chocolate of the day and i'm like a
caramel girl so i'd always go for the
caramel ones or my favorite are the
maraschino cherry ones i don't think
they have this there
travesty but anyways they do have a
caramel one and a hazelnut one which i
feel like that's ferrero rocher's game
so we're gonna go with that one and make
it into an amazing hunger crushing combo
let's do it okay so first of all
how classy you gotta get the little
plastic
topper to lock in the freshness
that way that they can keep it on the
shelves for like three years and not
just one okay
so
uh eeny meeny miny moe catch a tiger by
the
this one looks inviting
what's inside let's take a look okay so
according to this menu this one is the
milk cupola a feather light mousse
surrounded by rich milk chocolate
decorated with a dark chocolate flourish
sounds decadent
[Music]
i'm excited for this one like really
excited for this snack this is gonna be
good so we got some whole grain wrap
here we're going to get in there with
some almond butter
you could use peanut butter whatever
butter you like i'm getting near the end
here a little action here this is like
our glue we've got fresh pear i'm gonna
slice that apple would also work great
or any fruit really but pear is a really
nice high fiber option
and it's seasonal
and just like that
let's throw down some hemp hearts
because they go on everything
now our chocolate we're gonna do dark on
one milk on the other
[Music]
and i'm just gonna slice it
oh yeah
just like
that check out that
special luxurious rich moose dollar
store special folks can't go wrong then
we wrap just like this let's serve them
up all right i'm just going to top mine
off with a little bit of greek yogurt
and a sprinkle of cinnamon and a little
bit of pumpkin seeds for good measure
so it doesn't matter if you are team
dark chocolate or milk chocolate your
girl has something for ya so
let's break it down we've got loads of
fiber in the whole grain tortilla we've
got healthy fats fiber and protein in
the almond butter we've got some
pumpkin seeds on top we've got extra
protein in the greek yogurt more fiber
in the pear
like it's a match made in heaven and you
can kind of switch it up for flavor
depending on what chocolate truffle you
choose from the chocolate truffle box
eeny meeny miny moe catch a truffle by
the toe
this snack is a year-long snack
we got the crunch we got the sweet got
the stuff you got the
yes
well folks i hope that gave you a lot of
great inspiration on how to incorporate
your fear foods into everyday balanced
meals and snacks if you guys like this
video please be sure to give it the
thumbs up leave me a comment below on
some of your fear foods or trigger foods
and how you'd like to see me turn them
into hunger crushing combos subscribe to
the channel and i will see you next time
on abby's kitchen happy holidays bye
[Music]